perdemo-nos é o mesmo que estamos
desorientados
nós sabemos onde estamos de forma que
pode acontecer em vários sítios diversas
formas em vários momentos
uma coisa nós queremos estar perdidos
outra coisa não queriam estar pedidos
externos peritos involuntariamente
quando isso acontece temos sentimentos
negativos
nós podemos estar perdidos nas cidades
no meio de uma multidão do nosso amigo
podemos perder de nós próprios
podemos prever tempo podemos perder a
cabeça e podemos perder
perdida neles
por isso por denunciar e ficarmos sem
orientação estamos orientados de forma é
que nós podemos fazer para não estar nos
coretos podemos resgatar alguma coisa ou
alguém que nos orienta que nos guia e
cruz de uma direção do sítio onde nós
estamos para recebermos precisamente
qual é nossa localização por exemplo de
que forma é que se pode fazer uma
geolocalização no lugar como o deserto
de um carro como é que eu posso fazer
essa coisa como é que eu sabe onde está
e para onde vai
de que forma é que os orienta de forma
que se orientam os barcos nos oceanos ou
é um dos marcos da forma que orientam os
aviões
de que forma é que se orientam os
satélites no espaço
nós sabemos que ou no espaço no largo no
mar
não existe a ensiná-lo éticas que nos
possam orientar entanto conforme nós nos
problemas que forma nós não sabemos
orientar
é fácil utilizamos instrumentos de apoio
para que isso possa acontecer por
exemplo o gps as buscas os cronômetros
os municípios
os radares são instrumentos posteriores
e nós é desejo dos que nós utilizamos
para os orientados por exemplo de
mergulhadores de forma que as rodeados
de tanta água consegue receber um tostão
eu juntava edificados edifícios que os
permitam dizer eu conhecer significado
que eu sei onde estou não tem estradas
que os guia em média pessoas a quem
perguntar eles possam dizer você está
aqui neste preciso local
como é que os conseguem orientar no meio
daquele universo d'água por exemplo as
formigas quase cegas orientados por um
radar de odores e os à mão pelo faro
estas novas que o campo magnético
terrestre
os morcegos pelo som emitem sons
inaudíveis pelo homem que fazer o
retorno e que dão a sobre localiza
céu é velho pelo sol que são sensíveis
aos raios de ver e fazem dessa forma sua
localização e nós nós humanos como é que
nós orientamos nossos habitar em nós a
evitar que a cidade por exemplo
se formos um turista e consigamos fazer
um percurso pedestre e tivemos uma
cidade que não conhecemos
por exemplo no japão na bulgária x de
que forma é que não sabemos dizer enfim
vídeo daquela cidade nós estamos
localizados
é fácil utilizamos instrumentos como só
buscar no cabo frio que usam por exemplo
o mapa de papel
mapas digitais através de telemóveis gps
ou os tais pontos de referência
edificados da cidade ou perguntamos é
pessoas locais que nos digam em sítio é
que nós estamos localizados mas eu
pergunto os porque nós nos continuamos é
perder
mesmo utilizando estes sistemas de apoio
porque nós continuamos a não saber onde
está o nosso hotel onde é deixado
estacionado o carro até o parque de
estacionamento ou aquela loja onde vemos
a cerca de dez minutos mas o que sabemos
porquê e como vamos ver se através de
ouvir que eu não utilizarem o que é que
as pessoas sentem quando as pernas
não querendo de qualquer forma quando as
pessoas perdem não o crédito tem sempre
sensações do teor negativo ambiental
veja o vídeo que vai dizer através de
palavras que orgulhe de pessoas que
sentiram quais se poderão não querendo
dois cliques
vai ficar assim será para os prenderam
disseram que sempre é um embuste pânico
e desespero medo e satisfação e
segurança disseram todas banfield tração
disseram todas palavras de teor negativo
por isso quando nós vivemos em uma
cidade
o fato nos perdemos não significa que
esteja
se eu tiver essa orientação e confusa
desconforto e também segurança eu
pintasse medo
enfrenta ambos viram a treinar ali onde
stress challenge
rita chama muito nervosismo
o stress é vencer a corrida e esperar a
e compare a frustração na província de
impotência
por isso tudo palavras de george
negativo
creio que as pessoas sentem eu apurei
que é mais limitada a população se
périco involuntariamente estou esperto
não querendo eu volto a perguntar se
existe o gps porque as pessoas querem
porque as pessoas vão continuar a
aprender porque no uso de mesas aqui usa
o que acontece isso acontecer eu sou
designer da comunicação e design onde
trabalho que fiz foi o mapa turístico da
cidade do porto o qual inclui nem
investigação do doutoramento para tentar
desvendar de forma que eu poder resolver
a orientação ea perda dos turistas na
cidade utilizando os mapas
entretanto junto a esta questão com 11 é
possível também fazer faculdade de
psicologia da universidade do porto em
estudar qual é que o valor das imagens
de forma que nós entrevistamos as
imagens mas vemos três mobilizamos que
valor é que nós damos as imagens então
fiz uma triangulação aqui junto a este
tipo de informação e criar um sistema
que
com imagens ou tentativas apoiado e
mapas turísticos que faz com que os
turistas não se percam
por esse sistema vai fazer com que as
pessoas não se percam mais nas cidades
como o movimento vai ser breve
daqui é um par de meses ou mais
eu aqui vou levantar o véu e vou dar a
primazia de ser homem tem angular na
totalidade e não posso falar o cinema
para já mas vou votar livremente é nova
mamoré de nós podemos orientar
investigados em o gt como é que isto
pode funcionar é baseado no mapa de
papel ou no mapa digital e existem
desenhos orientativos que são colocadas
no mapa são café do mapa
esse design só três portos transportes
para a realidade em pontos estratégicos
da cidade em que as pessoas quando vêem
esses desenhos orientativos que com a
saber a sua localização está conseguem
saber precisamente onde estão fazendo eu
estou aqui porque acaba por ser a grande
diferença deste dia o gps é este novo
sistema não precisa de nada de apoio de
nenhuma tecnologia que faça que ajuda a
fazer alguma coisa possa este contou
somente com a vossa parte
é este é fácil e biologia para poderem
fazer eu posso conversar não precisa de
telemóveis de mais nenhum endereço é que
está o ponto de inovação destino vou dar
exemplos de como é que o pop que
obviamente funcionar quinta digital que
é por exemplo se viajamos para por
exemplo para o centro carga japão china
e turquia países nos quais desconhecemos
a língua despesas como é que nós perante
uma situação urbana estejamos como é que
nós sabemos um mês
há uma placa do carro ou qualquer outro
tipo de informação que me diga vamos ver
e sabemos onde estamos o nome do hotel
ao longo de uma rua
não sabemos e conhecemos esses
caracteres
este sistema criar e vai conseguir
informar com rápidas
o sítio da cidade onde é que nós estamos
localizados constaste desenhos
orientativos estamos exemplos nós não
temos que saber do mês a língua das
cidades para onde viajam anos
esse novo sistema chama-se ti cacho
henrique orienta chances tam e é uma
marca registrada com os direitos de
autor no projeto
outra questão é que eu tava porque tinha
frio vai funcionar como um mapa mental
por isso nós vamos prescindir daquela
sistema estuarino se aduz que o gps wifi
ramo em telemóveis tablets baterias rede
internet não vamos precisar de nada
disse para fazermos a nossa nunca avisa
sendo por isso vai funcionar como um
mapa mental
o sistema se cost de renda já existem
vai causou esta questão com os tais
desenhos orientativos colocados
estrategicamente na cidade que nós
quando os vemos conseguimos fazer a
nossa localização por exemplo se
tivermos em barcelona na primeira final
que é uma que tem uma extensão grande
como é que nós sabemos que estamos no
início quer coletivo nesse princípio ao
fim no início no meio ou no fim sentar
nos documentos uma medida deste gênero
como é que sabemos onde estamos com este
novo sistema se coce nós vamos conseguir
saber exatamente com rapidez
onde nós estamos localizados neder
com este tarde dançante orientativo
por exemplo se a nós conseguimos ver com
alguma rapidez sistema podemos transpor
também para os transportes públicos
metro e comboios autocarros como em
tempo real nós vamos conseguir saber
porque sítios da cidade é que estamos a
passar com este novo sistema estamos a
norte estamos a sul e oeste oeste em
sítio da cidade é que nós estamos
localizados e com precisão em sítio e
zona dos pontos cardeais e com precisão
e em tempo real estamos no transporte
público e vamos sendo informados através
dos pais dizem os orientativos porque se
tem é que nós estamos a passar na cidade
isso vai funcionar como um gps um amplo
faço época a organização precisa sair
nós precisarmos dos tais dispositivos
exteriores a nós utilizamos no nosso
corpo para fazenda localização e
utilizamos é que eu considero o mata
mental
não encontramos nada cimento nos cinco
continentes onde o trabalho foi
pesquisado esse tema pesquisado e
precisamos de mil pessoas para
concretizar uns os testes que fizemos
reais na cidade do porto testes que
fizemos em escala global ati ao
questionário fecharam em e turistas pois
nós perseguimos turistas para sabermos o
que eu achava como é que se comportavam
como é que os orientava os momentos de
velocidade
fizemos entrevistas é autor de mapas
europeus é que os desenham os mapas
digitais ou do papel
e não dizemos 400 matas dos cinco
continentes
estudamos sistemas de orientação em
manhattan em londres paris bristol
ensina e fizemos ensaios que a
solicitação é londres havaí e no porto
em terreno urbano e ainda colher os
dados estatísticos junto em que dados
mundiais acerca da perda do turista
precisa das pessoas
este sistema chama-se coche eu espero
que brevemente consigamos fazer que eu
consiga comer uns que é mental que
consiga de alguma forma orientar se
deixar criar cidades seguras e possa ter
certa forma ajudar pessoas com
que utilizam que não utiliza a visão
como os invisuais para se orientarem os
amblíopes pessoas com mobilidade
alterada e pessoas que utilizam a
audição para se orientarem como os
surdos mudos branco espero que
brevemente estranha ajudar toda a gente
na orientação das cidades muito obrigada
foi uma honra estar aqui